please
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
subscribe
sorry
yeah
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
on the end of the permanent mission of
India to the United Nations it's my
pleasure to extend a very warm welcome
to each and every one of you joining in
person but also to those who are
watching or listening to the live
webcast
this is a very special yoga event I
don't have to tell you that because most
of you already know it
we're experiencing a historic moment in
time today
as we celebrate this ninth anniversary
of world yoga day
we're honored to be joined by The
Honorable prime minister of India Modi
[Applause]
yeah
he'll be here with us very soon
this year's theme for World yoga day
is
you have it right here
last Tuesday
is his Sanskrit verse
which originates from the Indian
scriptures and it Loosely translates to
the concept that the whole world is one
family
yoga's popularity has exploded to every
corner of the globe
and it only continues to grow
we well know that yoga embodies Unity
Unity of mind or Consciousness and body
thought and action
restraint and fulfillment
and all of nature
a holistic approach to health
well-being
as well as experiencing a sense of Joy
or balance and peace
yoga is not only about physical
awesomeness
or just exercise
although we are very familiar with the
multitude of benefits that it can have
almost physical mental and even a
spiritual form
the fullest and richness of yoga is
about the suffering a sense of Oneness
fullness between considered
Consciousness and the external world
but also Oneness with the world of
nature
a deepened connection to the meaning of
life
in the words of one of the most famous
yoga practitioners
yoga cultivates to ways of maintaining a
balanced attitude in day-to-day life and
in our skill in the performance of one's
activities
I'd like to share with you a brief
overview of today's events
as The Honorable prime minister of India
arrives will be here with us on this
very stage
together with Her Excellency the
permanent representative of India to the
U.N Ambassador ruchira Campbell's
also we'll discussing Mr Chapo Karoshi
who is the president of the United
Nations
General Assembly and Mr Eric Adams for
instant mayor of the city of New York
but after these remarks we'll begin as a
group are yoga lesson
and will all follow a common yoga
teaching so that we can have a yoga
practice and experience that at the same
time together
our yoga instructor Miss Emily system
leading the demonstration along with the
upstairs and these are the ones who
deserve a lot of credit I'll call them
out so you know who they are the six
youngsters will be on the stage with us
are send Marie and Gaza
lyric honig
Ani
Daniela welcome whiskey
Connor who
as well
both will have other youngsters joining
us Below on the North Lawn in this first
row some of them are here already
and these youngsters are Kahari careless
Santiago advice
and giving support
come on yes
the yoga session will last for roughly
20 minutes and after that The Honorable
prime minister of India
I will announce the arrival of the Prime
Minister of India when he arrives at U.N
headquarters here and I ask that each
and every one of you take position
and I expect that everybody will be
ready on their yoga mat for the lesson
I also request that everyone in our
audience to please remain seated
please remain patience
please don't move around in case you
need any assistance
[Music]
whatsoever we have volunteers positioned
nearby and you will find out they're
here to assist you they have their
yellow caps on you take a look around
you'll see people with the yellow caps
these are our volunteers here to assist
should you need to use the facilities
while we're here you'll find them to
your right next to the Promenade by the
East River for our different stations
set up for your comfort
feel free to wear your yoga Day shirts
and I see that almost everybody has the
mom
and you look beautiful today I wish you
could see yourself the way I see it it's
really very very funny
with yellow Mouse on the Green
it is gorgeous what a gorgeous group we
have today here for World yoga day 2023.
yay
well how does it get any better than
that right I guess the answer is
um
you may have noticed right here on the
North Lawn we have a beautiful buses
and there is a quote on the plaque and
if you haven't seen it yet after this
event concludes you may want to take a
look and the quote is a famous spot of
boundary G which says there is no way to
peace
is the way
this cost of gandhiji was a special gift
by India to the U.S and it's the very
first culture of foundation here in New
York knob in the gardens it was unveiled
last December back in 2022 when the
minister of Journal affairs minister
jayashankar was here when he was
chairing the security Council back in
December of 2022.
and the Secretary General of the UL Mr
Antonio Gutierrez and the president of
the 77th unga Mr chavalo Karoshi and of
course ambassador
joined the external affairs minister at
the gandhiji Statue well
the Prime Minister gave a foreign
this moment for us to come together
for us to come together in ourself
to come and unite within us
to feel that in a resource that we have
that connection
oh holy truly all
that connection with one another
and that connection with
the Earth
these trees with the hair
with the Stillness that we all feel
that deep skills that connects everyone
everything
that Web of Life
I would like before we start in the next
few minutes
friends with little snails come to
Stillness as The Honorable prime
minister joins us
paying tribute as he does to the
gandhiji statue
I ask that we remain seated in our
father
foreign
minister of India
freeing Miranda Modi G has arrived
and he is now
being followed by many people
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you for continuing to stay in your
spot and be seated
we will start the program very shortly
and again if you need any assistance
whatsoever we have our volunteers
standing by to help they're wearing
their yellow caps so that you may
identify them easily
you can see many sculptures that we have
here on the North Lawn
but today the gandhiji statue is one
that is so dear to many of us here
the principles that he holds and
the concept of ahimsa is one that many
of us are very familiar with
that many world leaders are embodying
and we see this
as we look around to many people who aim
to be the change that they want to see
in the world
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
distinguished participants
yoga Masters
brothers and sisters
all of those watching on web TV and
joining us today
namaste
a very warm welcome to everyone
happy International Day of yoga 2023.
[Applause]
the time that we've all been waiting for
the time has come for me to share how
much we are deeply honored
we are so privileged to have with us
today
not other than the honorable prime
minister of India
[Music]
[Applause]
a distinguished world leader and an
Ardent yoga practitioner
I'd like to remind everyone that it is
Prime Minister Modi G himself back in
December 2014 who introduced the idea of
establishing World yoga day to the UN
General Assembly
a random number of
175 member states
recognized yoga's Universal appeal and
adopted The Landmark resolution
proclaiming June 21
as International yoga day the day of the
summer solstice here in Lemoore
so every 21 of June is World yoga day
this day provides people
everywhere across the globe all of us
and everyone watching an opportunity to
reflecting home the
benefits of practicing yoga indeed an
invaluable gift in the world from
India's speech to this
we thank the honorable prime minister of
India and it is
now celebrated worldwide with enthusiasm
and vigor
I will now begin the official part of
today's
events
India's permanent representative to the
United Nations to this day to deliver
her opening remarks
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
honorable prime minister SRI Narendra
Modi ji Mr President of the general
assembly Madame deputy secretary General
Mr Mayor distinguished ambassadors
distinguished guests and all my dear
friends and colleagues from this
wonderful audience
today's celebration is indeed very very
special prime minister Narendra Modi
will lead us in doing yoga here at the
United Nations lawns
to put matters in perspective it was
under his leadership and under his
guidance that 21st June was declared as
International yoga day and it is only
fitting therefore that the inspiration
behind the idea is with us today in the
scenic Multicultural setting of The
United Nations ladies and gentlemen it
is truly beautiful to see so many around
the world Gather in solidarity for yoga
it is not living with the burden of
wheat or the lightness of Oblivion
it is a choice made with balance and
idiosyncratic Beauty Timeless throughout
the progress of humanity yoga has
endured it is truth Beyond articulation
wisdom Beyond Time
I hope all of you will cherish 21st June
this year and hold it close to your
hearts
today and forever
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Ambassador camboge for your
remarks it's my turn now to invite The
Honorable president of the U.N General
Assembly Mr Chaba Karoshi for the stage
[Applause]
honorable prime minister
Madame deputy secretary General
Mr Mayor
Madam ambassador
dear friends
namaste
yoga is a way of uniting mind
and body
and also the environment
and us
the most memorable University lectures I
attended as a student many years ago
where on cultural traditions of ancient
Eastern civilizations
they helped me understand
that we are part of nature
despite regarding ourselves as
aristocratically detached from other
creatures
I also learned that the energies
in the universe
and inside us
abide
by the same law
a desire to achieve balance
yoga changes our physical performance
but more importantly
it can spark in US
different mental and intellectual
performance
with a control that it teaches over
ourselves we learn how to make change
and impact
since that University lecture
have been an admirer of yoga
I'm very proud of my daughter
who has already reached a high level of
practice
and is continuing her journey
thanks to her I understand better yoga's
ethical guide guide
the guide which includes the principle
of non-stealing
non-greed
non-harding
and non-violence
in other words
yoga's ethical guide To Living is a
guide to sustainability
not overusing resources that belong to
all of us
not prioritizing short-term gains over
planetary boundaries
and working for transformation
our world needs balance
self-control and creativity just as it
needs recognition of moral
responsibilities and cherishing peace
and justice
there are many ways to approach these
aims
yoga is one of the means for which I
have a special respect
I'm happy to be here with all of you
today
but let me apologize in advance
I am not a yoga prediction practitioner
and the positions which you will show
might look very different from what I
end up doing
still I'm here
with an open heart
and open mind
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you president karosi for
highlighting the transformative power of
yoga and in such a very personal way
at this time I would now ask that mayor
Eric Adams the mayor of the city of New
York please take the stage
to
Prime Minister Modi
to president of the general assembly
to deputy secretary General
to your excellencies
to the Ambassador
to all of you
do not miss the significance of this
moment
New York City is
the largest and most important city in
America
as I stand before you as the mayor of
that City
I share with you in a clear and a
universal tone
that we are no longer focused solely on
the physical body but the anatomy of our
spirit
for far too long we have separated what
our needs are emotionally spiritually
and physically
we are going to go to the root causes of
that which troubles many of us
from how we interact to the food we eat
to allowing our children to have
breathing exercises in the morning as
they start this school day to challenge
the mental health issue that's impacting
us
but there's a larger challenge for all
of us
what we do on the mat and practicing
yoga must become what we do on the
streets and in our countries
we cannot become universally connected
through the yellow Maps we lay on but
disconnected as we move through our
communities use the spirit and emotions
of yoga to challenge and fight against
war to fight against gender oppression
to fight against violence to fight
against a lack of clean water to fight
against the food insecurity to fight
against the destruction of our planet
our connectivity is not only how we
connect you to our families and our
parents we have two mothers one gave
birth to us and one sustains us yoga
keeps us connected to both mothers and
connected to each other this
International yoga day is an
international call for us to stand up
for humankind across the globe in all
living being I'm proud to be here and
I'm proud to symbolically represent this
city as stating the international yoga
day is an international call that we
will be a leader here in New York City
as you are a leader but in your own
environments thank you for allowing me
to Rejoice with you today
[Applause]
thank you mayor Adams for spotlighting
how
yoga is integral to the anatomy of one's
Spirit we appreciate that perspective
and input
I'd like now to go to the video message
of un Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez who is not available to be
with us in person but is here in spirit
please let us go to the videotape
happy International Day of yoga I want
to recognize Prime Minister Modi for all
he has done to promote understanding of
yoga and its many benefits
yoga unites it unites body and mind
humanity and nature and millions of
people across the globe for whom it is a
source of strength Harmony and peace
in a dangerous and divided Worlds the
benefits of this ancient prac